this video is brought to you by
manscape.com
we have an urgent psa a pubic service
announcement
manscape's best-selling performance
package bundle
is now available for international
shipping
it comes with the weed whacker a trimmer
that's engineered for your ear
and nose so you can safely remove the
nasty hairs inside
are you ready i'm just kidding
you went deep actually i've been using
that a lot
the same one mine might i actually use
that one but my nose hair grows so much
to the point where it's touching my
upper lip now oh damn
that's pretty long you're all japanese
man i know i should let it grow and see
what it looks like
connected to your mustache yeah i should
shave but then just keep the
nose hair going but i'm not gonna let
that [ __ ] grow i got
the weed whacker the lawnmower 3.0
a waterproof cordless trimmer with skin
safe technology so you can confidently
groom around your balls
and avoid nicks and snags ouch because i
cut my bowels before
no ouchie oh look at that
you can see the ball sack you can't see
you can see the ball
oh plus all this other great stuff like
ball deodorant ball toner
the magic map you can shave your balls
on this or crack a crab
and eat it for the men's best grooming
and hygiene
go to www.manscape.com
jknews for 20 off and free international
shipping
we'll have the link in the description
box below go get it
thank you damaski for keeping our pubes
trimmed and our nose free of weeds
look at how fresh that is
[Music]
all right sherry do you tic doc i have
the app
but i haven't been active no no like do
you do you scroll down do you watch the
technique i don't
actually it can i be real or should i be
fake
i don't actually either yeah i could be
thick now i do some scrolling
love i love this girl i'm a scroller
this thumb
gets the most action oh you for many
reasons oh
isn't that kind of like too hard yeah
actually you're right the thumbnail
the thumb actually does nothing in that
process huh no she's doing this
yeah this is for the butt just the butt
just for my butt
tick-tock tick-tock on the butt
well there's this new um this new trend
which i find it really hilarious that
new york post is calling it a
disturbing new tic toc trend but you'll
see why it's so disturbed
um so i will play the
one of the videos of the tik tok trend
thingy which is with
mark cuban oh he got on the trend
and his 17 year old daughter alexis
cuban oh
to her tick tock okay okay i like these
like celebrity and kid
they're kid tick tocks it's pretty funny
it says cuban yeah here we go
so this is the trend it's like it's the
audio with
text over it and the parent scanning and
here we go
wait what i own a basketball team and
this [ __ ] can't even make a free
throw oh
i thought he was actually gonna do
something yeah wait what's the trend
i just told you it's it's so no ending
oh
they're talking they're kids it's pretty
much just parents roasting their kids
oh the text there's nothing happening
really in the background or unless like
the kids doing something
is aren't they roasting isn't she
roasting him no
so he's the one that has it oh my god
this is so funny
so he's the one that has the selfie
camera on right so he's talking to the
camera with the text
and then he's talking about his daughter
oh
she's the [ __ ] yes he's calling
her daughter his daughter a [ __ ]
this [ __ ] can't even do a free
throw
yeah and i own a basketball team yeah
there's no free throw though so the
whole thing is just like
you're just making fun of your kid for
whatever reason by flexing about
yourself
right and then the kid is posting it on
their their tick tock or
most cases that's what's happening she
should have been missing a free throw in
that video yeah cause i'm like you're
overthinking it guys this is tick-tock
exactly that's why i'm like this is
hilarious i have to explain it to you
all that's [ __ ]
old okay i get it tick-tock videos are
very complicated there's like mini
documentaries on there now there's some
really fun ones yeah no there's some
good stuff
and then there's this yeah i mean
okay boomer
there were some that actually i cracked
up in okay so
um okay so that's the that's the audio
and then the whole thing is the parents
panning right
now it's no no no no but you know what's
crazy about that [ __ ]
before you move on that audio is from a
guy who beat boxes
and there's no special effects on it
mike thompson or whatever no no it's not
mike thompson this dude rick sent it to
me and it's that guy look i don't know
how
uh if he added anything afterwards but
the video is just him beatboxing
it sounds like it's like late i know
wait i gotta hear it again no no no
no no no no no no no no no beatboxer
these days like harmonize
themselves yeah yeah yeah that's why
this [ __ ] was crazy some next level [ __ ]
again but i wanna show you the video i
just wanna listen
to you man you gotta stop trying to find
the og video
after you show us the challenge
that's all it is that's pretty good all
right so i'm going to show you
screenshots of
other ones okay yeah please i need more
because this one says [ __ ] just
said she was
she wishes she wasn't born me too [ __ ]
all i wanted was a back rub
is it too late to get a refund and then
so
in the background she was just like
opening the refrigerator some [ __ ] like
just doing
some regular exactly it's like it's
parent tick tocks
yeah some some of them yeah and then
this one says this [ __ ] forgot
to defrost the chicken just like i
forgot to take my birth control oh i've
seen this one actually it has type
that's funny i think i'll write one for
my dad and just have him hold the camera
yeah
that's pretty much what they're doing
yeah so all the kids are writing these
probably yeah yeah yeah this other one
this [ __ ] just asked if he's
adopted fam i'd never pick you
that's funny another one seriously
considering voting for trump so he'll
outlaw gay adoption and we can return it
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no that's literally what's playing on
the background see these are funny the
mark cuban one was just like a mess
he's rich he's a celebrity that's what i
started off with stick to owning [ __ ]
man
no no no no no no no no no no one says
how the [ __ ] is my daughter latina and
still got no ass
like nah she ate mine that's actually
more ass than i have for sure no no no
no
no no no no no no no no [ __ ] that's
hilarious i gotta write something for my
dad i don't know she had a cute little
booty i should have pulled out 15 years
ago
now i'm stuck with him someone adopt
this [ __ ]
nice another one i got all a's and was
the smartest kid in every class just for
this [ __ ] not to know her times
table at 15. is it too late to return
her
yeah no no no why is mr miyagi there
how is this [ __ ] gay and
colorblind what like what brain brawl
are you seeing
that's a funny ass one this one uh
[ __ ] dented my car and said it
was an accident fam so were you
damn next one you look good
[ __ ] told me the other day
someone tried to scam him
fam you the scammer i waited nine months
just for you to look half finished
oh my gosh oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
is this a video yeah it's a video so the
kids can play it
no no no no no i scream it's a
screenshot of the video oh no
like he has like some sort of all right
so that that kid
so he for sure about that himself
because he's super self-aware and he's
always making jokes like that about
himself and how he looks and stuff
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh my god this just
got really dark but um
those yeah those are good though those
are good i feel like the kids are
writing it because the paper yeah
they're
typed that way for sure yeah but it's so
right they can't even like the
first generation can't that's why i
laughed hard at this at this uh
new york post it says parents verbally
trash their own kids in brutal tick tock
trend
it's like this disturbing new trend on
disturbing
disturbing you don't get it i'm gonna go
home and just write a bunch of jokes
dad hold the camera real quick that's
basically what's happening huh okay give
us one up
your head
i immigrated to this country um
with no money just to raise a kid that
makes
internet videos for a living
[Music]
the the immigrating to this country want
like that
that theme is pretty popular in this
this trend the
can i abort so can i abort them at 18 is
another
like common comment common theme yeah
yeah that's the word
yeah common theme here yeah but what do
you think you can do that with your own
kid
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] yeah relax
when the baby comes out but that's
actually pretty funny if you go the baby
get the baby oh yeah facts
dude you can actually do it
[Laughter]
what would you do for isaac um honestly
i would just because now he's
old enough where i'm like you roast
yourself and i'll do it
oh because you might want to see it and
go why'd you say that
yeah no because right now 12 year old
emotions are very
you know right right is it pretty high
you know i mean they're in two of their
emotions now yeah
like really in tune and like i remember
being his age and getting something that
my mom would tell me and
twisting it to be the most malicious
like intent ever so i'm like
it might traumatize him you don't want
to be a part of that clown on him he
won't take you won't understand that's
like clowning
my dad clowned on me when i was 12. it's
because we don't get along like that
you have to create the report him a lot
like like we just don't have that type
of
relationship so then for it to come out
of the blue it'll be like
bullying yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm like
i'm not about that i feel like
from the ages of 11 and 12 those ages
didn't matter
those two one of them don't matter 13
13 and on is what mattered to me wait
how come 11 and 12
i don't remember that's why it was the
most traumatic wait
what is that junior high yeah pretty
much seventh and eighth 12th
dude i had a [ __ ] blast man so blind
was playing on the radio
and uh six seven eighths was moving all
the time oh yeah those were skating days
i think i fell a lot hmm i remember
12 was a cool year for me because i
remember going from fifth grade to sixth
grade
because sixth grade was twelve i think
and i remember like 11.
sixth grade seventh grade no no cause
isaac is 12 now he's in seventh
he's twelve going on third yeah sixth
grade seventh grade yeah twelve going on
thirteen
right i'm sorry in sixth grade is when
like the peak of like the kids calling
us chino and stuff like that i feel like
that was the peak of that i know i was
[ __ ] i had a great time bro
well i started my period in sixth grade
too so that was a big year for me oh
like i would never know how to like rock
the pad
yeah like i would always put it too far
back or too far forward
so i had uniform too it was in alhambra
so i would wear these khaki pants
and i would leak like every [ __ ] day
no so then i would have to like tie my
sweater around my waist with the front
version like an apron
oh [ __ ] because it was just i was bloody
i was bleeding the [ __ ] out
you were learning i was learning that
was it i mean well you probably didn't
have any skid marks
no skidzings no skid plates choose
between skid marks and period leaks and
you said
no skid marks what do i do i remember my
first period i would
actually put two pads one in the front
one was thick too
[ __ ] [ __ ] diaper at that point is
that a training pad is that why it's
that thick
no i don't know you know it's because we
use our moms that's why
we use our mom's face i don't know why
is it so it's like a depends
yeah and then back then they didn't have
the technology as advanced as they do
today where it's like
thinner pads no back then it was like
[ __ ] this thick it was
like a rice ball this
yeah no i got [ __ ] lucky because my
very first period i got it the very
first day of spring break so
the whole week i was only at home wow
what did you do did you call your mom
like what would you do when you first
got it i was just like
ah i'm gonna get boobs now i was just so
excited but it was in the morning i went
to the toilet and i saw like
blood yeah i told my mom and i was like
please don't tell my stepdad and she
goes tiffany got her period
i'm like ah i was home alone and i
called my mom and she was like well you
know what to do right like we trained
for this
you guys trained for parents no but she
was like well you know what to do right
get out the newspaper and lay down yeah
yeah
can you say newspaper drop your pants
and wait
you're potty training a puppy do you
guys remember when you first
do you guys remember when you first got
like your first pube mm-hmm yes one
queue had one
i was in seventh grade seventh grade and
all the homies got them in sixth grade
and i was like oh man they all got pubes
and then i remember when i finally got
my first one in seventh grade i was like
yes
and then i told my parents and they're
like show us all right i'm like
all right fine it was on your balls or
your uh no i don't actually go any
hair on my balls the mound area yeah it
was on my it was on the
no no here i had all of my balls did you
get it here first or here first the
man's pupils oh
you're a harmless cat pretty much i
barely have any
uh armpit hair uh and i had one it was
like the puke my pubes
the pubes are above my genital region
maybe like pubis is is that is that what
the bone the mouth the yeah sure pubic
bone
i always thought man's pubis only
referred to like uh the female region or
am i tripping
mom pubis is that a greek god
that's the mound oh it's the rounded ma
okay it's the rounded mass of fatty
tissue lying over the joint of the pubic
bones in women typically more prominent
and also called mons
varane varan so it's on the wall what's
on the label
the peels are where the views are yeah
except none of my actual balls but yeah
seventh grade
wow yeah i have it on my balls i didn't
get one single pube
like once you haven't ever i didn't get
like one particular pew that came out it
was just like peach fuzz that eventually
got darker and thicker
oh my god a similar thing i feel like i
remember seeing one
i remember seeing the one same with my
armpit hair it was like it was just
peach fuzz and then eventually it got
darker
no it might not see i hardly have armpit
it's like it's like really long right
now
i just stopped giving a [ __ ] in
quarantine but it's very scattered like
it's not abundant
you know what i mean so it's like it's a
it's a really long it's like look at
that
really dude i probably yeah there's
probably like 12. i got like six
to the other i counted word no like here
i have like four
here and maybe like nine or twelve over
here so you just pluck
you don't yeah wait why do you have so
because i lasered that's why
oh we're talking about natural sit here
hold on
no dude i'm mexican [ __ ] that hair
how do you only have six no it's harry
you